Because your charm may not be enough to save you,...
...try some other ways to stop the laughter.
You will need: common sense, sad thoughts, physical pain, and an apology.
Optional: acting skills
Step one: Know when it is inappropriate to laugh.
If you are unsure, ask your mother or someone you can trust.
Step two: Check out others in the room to see if they share your impulse.
If they don't, divert your attention quickly by starting another conversation.
Step three: Think negative or sad thoughts to dampen your mood.
It's usually tension that precedes outbreaks of inappropriate laughter.
Step four: Pinch yourself or bite the inside of your mouth or your lip...
...to contain yourself.
Physical pain can quell laughter.
Step five: Disguise your reaction by faking a coughing fit,...
...using your hand to cover your grin.
This allows you to leave the room and compose yourself.
Step six: Clamp a hand over your mouth and exhale quickly...
...to rob the laugh of fuel.
If caught, apologize without trying to explain, which may add insult to injury.
A laugh can appear to be a crying fit if you are at a funeral or in a sad situation,...
...but it will take good acting.
Step seven: Grit your teeth while pushing your tongue against your palate.
If you have to release it, do it without a smile...
...so people aren't sure what you're responding to.
Did you know?
Pathologic laughing or crying can result from severe brain injury.